This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的方法。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。1984年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done. need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
播客。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控为双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷g，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。我发誓，我要做他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。请在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, guys, I'm going back to uni. I'm going back to the time when I was a full-time student. I'm taking a trip down memory lane to talk about the academic and study tips that I absolutely swore by when I was a student that I would use again. if I was back there, or if I wanted straight A's, if I wanted to be valedictorian,
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时经历的最大变化、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目中，欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理学。今天，伙计们，我要回到大学去了。我要回到我当全日制学生的那个时期。我要进行一次记忆之旅，谈谈当我还是个学生时我绝对深信不疑的学习和学习技巧，如果我回到那个时期，或者如果我想拿全A，如果我想成为毕业典礼告别辞演讲者，我会再次使用这些技巧。
if I wanted my transcript to be the best it could be by the end of the year. I'm honestly surprised I've never done an episode like this because when I was still getting my degrees, I genuinely loved the art of studying. Also, I know there are so many of you who are getting their diplomas, getting their undergrad degrees, getting their masters. Some of you are even getting your PhDs and you are still trying to find the most time, cost effective and successful study tips to become the academic weapon you always dreamed of being. So this episode feels very necessary. These tips aren't going to be boring. I'm not going to tell you to use flashcards or to read the lecture notes or the Pomodora technique. We know that. Those are tried and
如果我想让我的成绩单在年底时达到最好。说实话，我很惊讶我从来没有做过这样一集节目，因为当我还在攻读学位时，我真的非常热爱学习的艺术。另外，我知道你们当中有很多人正在获得文凭、本科学位、硕士学位。你们有些人甚至在攻读博士学位，你们仍然在努力寻找最省时、最具成本效益和最成功的学习技巧，以成为你一直梦想成为的学术武器。所以这一集感觉非常必要。这些技巧不会很无聊。我不会叫你用闪卡，或者去读讲义，或者用番茄工作法。我们都知道这些。那些都是经过时间考验的
true, we are talking instead the really strange things I would do based on research because when you understand the psychology of how to study well, everything changes. You end up studying less, you have more time for you, you get better grades because you essentially understand how to tune your brain to absorb knowledge efficiently. If you just take notes in class and you highlight them and, you know, you repeat them to yourself, that's level one. I want to take you to level 10 of the study game using the science. So I have, I think, six tips for you today, things that, the exact things I did to be high school valedictorian to get a national merit scholarship to maintain a near perfect GPA when I was at uni. I know these work. I have the evidence
实用的方法，我们要讨论的是我根据研究会做的那些非常奇怪的事情，因为当你了解如何高效学习的心理学时，一切都变了。你最终会花更少的时间学习，你有更多的时间留给自己，你取得更好的成绩，因为你基本上了解了如何调整你的大脑以高效地吸收知识。如果你只是在课堂上记笔记，然后把它们高亮标记，然后，你知道，对自己重复它们，那是第一级。我想利用科学带你进入学习游戏的第10级。所以我今天大概有六个技巧给你，这些事情，正是我在高中时成为毕业典礼告别辞演讲者、获得国家优秀奖学金、在大学时保持接近完美GPA所做的具体事情。我知道这些方法管用。我有证据
to back it up. So without further ado, let's get into the best. psychology hacks for studying. Stay with us. So when you're studying, whatever the subject is, the ultimate goal is to convert information from your short-term or working memory to your long-term memory. And then I always like to think of another layer of this, which is your application memory, not just being able to recite, but to integrate into everyday experiences. Seems like a simple formula, right? But getting it to that long-term application storage basically requires integrating the information in a significant way. And what I mean by a significant way is that you have to show your brain this information
来支持这一点。那么废话不多说，让我们进入最佳学习心理学秘诀。请继续收听。所以当你学习时，无论是什么科目，终极目标是将信息从你的短期或工作记忆转化为你的长期记忆。然后我总是喜欢想到这一点的另一个层面，那就是你的应用记忆，不仅能够背诵，而且能够将其融入日常生活经验中。这看起来像是一个简单的公式，对吧？但要让它进入长期应用存储，基本上需要以一种有意义的方式整合信息。我所说的有意义的方式是指你必须向你的大脑展示这些信息
is important and worth remembering either through repetition, recall, practical application, applying it to your personal circumstances or any number of techniques that you may have used in the past or still do use. Your brain receives hundreds of, of thousands, if not millions of pieces of information every day. So your brain needs a signal for what is important. And that signal is a deliberate behavior like study methods, like repetition, like any of those things that is saying to your brain, hey, this is something we care about. We want to learn this. The thing is, there is a hierarchy here. And the more personal significance, you can apply to new information the better. And the further up the hierarchy, the method will be,
很重要，并且值得记住，可以通过重复、回忆、实际应用、将其应用到你的个人环境中，或者你在过去使用过或现在仍在使用的任何数量的技巧。你的大脑每天接收成百上千甚至数百万条信息。所以你的大脑需要一个信号来表明什么是重要的。而这个信号是一种刻意的行为，比如学习方法、比如重复、比如任何那些向你的大脑发出信号的行为，嘿，这是我们在乎的事情。我们想学习这个。问题是，这里有一个等级制度。你可以将更多个人意义应用到新信息中，效果就越好。而且这种方法在等级制度中的位置就越高，
basically. Recall, like, repetition is pretty low. But when you start to apply personal information to what you are learning, you start to move up the latter. In fact, a 2024 study from Rice University titled Why People Remember found that information that has emotional significance and personal significance has a longer, essentially like memory shelf life. And that makes sense. You don't forget, you don't forget your dog's name. You don't forget the girls who bullied you in the fifth grade or your favorite songs. You don't forget the lyrics to those because those memories are often encoded differently. This hack, the hack is encoding the information you're studying in the same way as that personally significant information so that you can recall it easier. Most people, again,
基本上。回忆，比如，重复是相当低的。但当你开始将个人信息应用到你正在学习的内容上时，你开始顺着阶梯往上爬。事实上，莱斯大学2024年的一项名为《人们为什么会记住》的研究发现，具有情感意义和个人意义的信息基本上具有更长的记忆保质期。这很合理。你不会忘记，你不会忘记你狗的名字。你不会忘记在五年级欺负你的那些女孩，也不会忘记你最喜欢的歌曲。你不会忘记这些歌词，因为这些记忆通常是以不同的方式编码的。这个秘诀，这个秘诀就是将你正在学习的信息以与那些具有个人意义的信息相同的方式进行编码，这样你就能更容易地回忆起它们。大多数人，再次强调，
will do the following. They will take notes. They will read those notes. They will highlight those notes. they will repeat the information in the same form as much as possible, and they will hope that they will remember it, and they will probably get a nice 75 on the test. Here's the technique that I would use instead. First, obviously still take notes. But take notes as if you are writing the textbook yourself, with chapters, with headings, with formulas, with visuals,
会做以下事情。他们会记笔记。他们会阅读那些笔记。他们会高亮标记那些笔记。他们会尽可能以相同的形式重复这些信息，他们会希望自己能记住它，他们可能会在考试中得到一个不错的75分。以下是我会使用的替代技巧。首先，显然还是要记笔记。但记笔记时要像你自己编写教科书一样，有章节、有标题、有公式、有视觉元素，
and keep it all in the same document on your computer. Pretend you are literally the author. Someone is going to, your notes are going to be what informs the next cohort. So you want to make it look good. You want to make it very, not complex, but in depth. And you want to structure it so that it's coherent. When it comes time to study for an exam or a midterm, whatever it is, up the font size of that document to 16, double space the whole document,
并且把它们全部保存在电脑里的同一个文档中。假装你 literalmente 就是作者。有人会，你的笔记将成为下一届学生的参考资料。所以你想让它看起来很好。你想让它变得非常，不是复杂，而是深入。你想构建它，使其连贯。当到了为考试或期中考试复习的时候，无论是什么考试，把那个文档的字号放大到16号，整个文档双倍行距，
print out those notes, staple them together, or buy. them as if they are a book. This is what I always did. I wish that I had like a picture of what this looks like. I just feel like it looks so much better visually so you can understand it. But your notes should almost look like a movie manuscript, like a big bound book. Now we're still going to use those tried and true recall or study methods. Step one, obviously like you have to go through and highlight. And I know I said that's not an effective method. I know. But it's just stage one of integration. You obviously just need to know what information is crucial. Stage two, I want you to go through and in those lines, because you've double-fonded it, in those margins, I want you to
把那些笔记打印出来，订在一起，或者买。把它们当成一本书。我总是这样做。我真希望我有这张照片看看它是什么样的。我只是觉得它在视觉上看起来好多了，所以你能理解它。但你的笔记应该看起来像电影剧本，像一本装订成册的大书。现在我们仍然要使用那些经过时间考验的回忆或学习方法。第一步，显然你得通读并高亮标记。我知道我说过这不是一种有效的方法。我知道。但这只是整合的第一阶段。你显然只需要知道哪些信息是至关重要的。第二步，我希望你通读并在这些行之间，因为你设置了双倍字号，在那些空白处，我希望你
write text, interesting tidbits, facts, underline, draw pictures around your notes, make them really personal. Step three, read through your notes again and tell yourself the story of what you're reading by applying it to something you see in your own life or in the world. For example, if you are studying, I don't know, psychopathology, and the section you are reviewing is on schizophrenia, write out the symptoms like you're describing a movie character, or you're telling the story of someone's behavior that you know, or somebody in the news, or somebody, yeah, or a character in a movie. If you're studying systems of voting or politics and you have a big chunk of notes that are all very theoretical about voting systems, imagine your friends as candidates in each of those voting systems. Any kind of personal association is going to work amazingly. The final step is to take your notes, take your research and do one of three things. Either explain it to someone else in your life.
写下文字、有趣的花絮、事实、画下划线、在笔记周围画画，让它们真正具有个人色彩。第三步，再次通读你的笔记，通过将你正在阅读的内容应用到你在自己生活中或世界上看到的事情上，给自己讲讲你正在阅读的内容的故事。例如，如果你正在学习，我不知道，精神病理学，你正在复习的部分是关于精神分裂症的，把症状写下来，就像你在描述一个电影角色，或者你在讲述你认识的某个人、新闻中的某个人、或者某个人，是的，或者电影中的角色的行为故事。如果你正在学习投票系统或政治，并且你有一大堆关于投票系统的非常理论化的笔记，想象你的朋友们是这些投票系统中各自的候选人。任何形式的个人联想法都会产生惊人的效果。最后一步是拿出你的笔记，拿出你的研究，做以下三件事中的一件。要么向你生活中的其他人解释它，
life or prepare like essentially a small lecture on your topics. This is known as the Fenman technique. Research has shown it's one of the most effective study techniques you can use when you can teach it back to somebody else. You know it at a depth that is hard to come by because it asks you to almost be the expert. It asks you to adopt the skills and knowledge you'd need to be an expert. So teach it to somebody else to turn it into something creative. I used to do these big mind-mack. and like diagrams and doodles on it. I used to actually get like a massive poster board to remember psychology concepts back at uni
生活，或者基本上为你的主题准备一个小讲座。这被称为费曼技术。研究表明，当你能把它教回给别人时，它是你能使用的最有效的学习技巧之一。你对它的了解达到了很难达到的深度，因为它要求你几乎成为专家。它要求你具备成为专家所需的技能和知识。所以把它教给别人，把它变成有创意的东西。我以前会做这些大型思维导图。和上面的图表涂鸦。我以前在大学里实际上会买那种巨大的海报板来记住心理学概念
and I would make like this poster. In high school I would get a whiteboard marker and I would write my notes and I would like draw diagrams and all that stuff on my windows and on my mirrors. So process it creatively. Or write down your notes as personal questions and do at least 20 of them and answer them. So questions like,
我会做这样的海报。在高中时，我会拿着白板笔写笔记，在窗户上和镜子上画图表和所有这些东西。所以要以有创意的方式处理它。或者把你的笔记写成个人问题，至少写20个并回答它们。所以像这样的问题，
If I had to choose the biology concept I knew the least about from this year, what would it be? And then describe that concept. Or like, what's another one? Like, what term did I find most interesting? What applies most to my life? What area am I most fascinated by? Like, make the questions personally relevant, then answer them. Again, all these methods work because we are trying to encode on a deeper, a more specific, personally relevant level. It's like when you do this, when you adopt one of those final three methods on top of those other methods, you are solidifying an idea in concrete, not in paper. Another element to this is to understand your learning style.
如果我必须选择今年我所知最少的生物学概念，会是什么？然后描述那个概念。或者像，还有什么？比如，我觉得哪个术语最有趣？哪个最贴近我的生活？哪个领域最让我着迷？比如，让这些问题具有个人相关性，然后回答它们。同样，所有这些方法之所以有效，是因为我们试图在更深、更具体、个人相关的层面上进行编码。就像当你这样做时，当你除了那些其他方法之外还采用最后三种方法中的一种时，你是在把一个想法浇筑在水泥里，而不是写在纸上。另一个要素是了解你的学习风格。
Research says there's eight learning stars. And each of these learning stars was adapted from Gardner's theory of multiple intelligences. So basically he developed this idea back in the 80s to essentially argue that IQ is just one specific type of intelligence. It's a general intelligence, but real intelligence comes in many different forms, there's many different understandings, and your natural inclination for a specific form is what's going to help you excel in a certain area. Basically, people are smart at different things, people are good at different things, but these forms are visual or spatial. So some people have a visual or spatial learning type. That's a preference for things laid out in maps, laid out in graphs, laid out in charts. Auditory, like an auditory learning style.
研究表明有八种学习星。其中每一颗学习星都是根据加德纳的多元智能理论改编的。所以基本上他在80年代发展了这个想法，基本上是为了争论智商只是一种特定类型的智商。它是一种一般智能，但真正的智能有许多不同的形式，有许多不同的理解，你对特定形式的自然倾向将帮助你在某个特定领域脱颖而出。基本上，人们在不同的事情上很聪明，人们擅长不同的事情，但这些形式是视觉或空间的。所以有些人有视觉或空间学习类型。这是对以地图、图表、图表布局的事物的偏好。听觉，比如听觉学习风格。
So you like to absorb knowledge through sound, song, rhythm, beat, kinesthetic, learning through movement, having a, I guess, a natural intelligence for how your body moves and what it doesn't space and what it can do. verbal, the use of speech and speaking concepts or ideas allowed. This is my learning style. Obviously, no surprise. I run a podcast, but another one is logical. There are people who really enjoy learning or absorbing information by laying them down in a very mathematical and logical format. Interpersonal and intrapersonal.
所以你喜欢通过声音、歌曲、节奏、节拍来吸收知识，动觉，通过运动学习，拥有一个，我想，对于你的身体如何运动以及它在空间中如何运动、它能做什么的自然智能。言语，大声使用言语和口语概念或想法。这是我的学习风格。显然，这并不奇怪。我经营一个播客，但另一个是逻辑。有些人非常喜欢通过以非常数学和逻辑的格式布局来学习或吸收信息。人际和内省。
Two different ones. Interpersonal, learning through collaboration, conversation, connection, intrapersonal, learning through reflection, alone time, deep devotion, solitude. And then finally, naturalistic, learning through the world by seeing patterns, by connecting things to one's surroundings. Hopefully you got all those, but there's eight. And the theory goes that this also aligns not just to how you best process information, but also what job might suit you best.
两种不同的。人际，通过合作、对话、连接来学习，内省，通过反思、独处时间、深沉的奉献、独处来学习。最后是自然主义，通过观察模式、将事物与周围环境联系起来来了解世界。希望你记住了所有这些，但有八种。理论是，这不仅与你如何最好地处理信息有关，还与什么工作最适合你有关。
We don't have time to get into that because that theory is very wild and wacky. But I think, again, it's important to know your preference and tune into how you can better absorb information based on how your brain best sees information. And when you can do that, it becomes so much easier. I feel like it's like falling into a stream.
我们没有时间深入探讨这个，因为那个理论非常狂野古怪。但我认为，再次强调，了解你的偏好并根据你的大脑如何最好地看到信息来调整你如何更好地吸收信息是很重要的。当你能做到这一点时，它就会变得容易得多。我觉得这就像落入一条溪流。
It's hard to explain. But when you start learning in a memory, absorbing information in your brains, one of your brain's preferred ways, there is just so much less cognitive friction. Here is how to figure out what yours is, because I feel like I gave you all of that, and I didn't give you the answer to how to find out. Four questions. When you have to explain something you care about to someone, how do you prefer doing it? Do you immediately grab a pen? Do you draw them a map? Do you connect it to a personal experience? Do you use your body?
这很难解释。但是当你开始在一篇记忆中学习时，在你的大脑中吸收信息，这是你大脑偏爱的方式之一，认知摩擦就会少得多。以下是如何弄清楚你的是哪一种，因为我觉得我给了你所有这些，而我没有告诉你如何找到答案的答案。四个问题。当你必须向某人解释你关心的事情时，你更喜欢怎么做？你是否立即抓起一支笔？你给他们画地图吗？你把它和个人经历联系起来吗？你用你的身体吗？
Do you use your hands? Do you work through the logic with them? Question two. When someone explains a complex idea to you, what makes it click for you? Is it examples? Is it metaphors, discussion? Is it seeing it in action? Is it getting to just sit and just process it and wiki it and research it?
你用你的手吗？你和他们一起梳理逻辑吗？第二个问题。当别人向你解释一个复杂的想法时，是什么让它对你茅塞顿开？是例子吗？是隐喻、讨论吗？是看到它付诸行动吗？是能够坐下来处理它、在维基百科上查阅并研究它吗？
Third question, think back now to your school or uni days if you are not still in those places. what kind of classes felt easiest to stay engaged in, even when the content wasn't that interesting. That's another clue. And finally, if you had unlimited time to learn something purely for enjoyment, what would that learning environment look like? How would you want to learn about the thing you are choosing to learn about? Now, the thing to know, our style isn't always consistent,
第三个问题，现在回想一下你的学校或大学时代，如果你现在不在那些地方的话。什么样的课程让你觉得最容易保持专注，即使内容并不是那么有趣。这是另一个线索。最后，如果你有无限的时间纯粹为了娱乐而学习某些东西，那个学习环境会是什么样子？你希望如何了解你选择学习的东西？现在，需要知道的一点是，我们的风格并不总是连贯的，
and there's not just one for you, like there's often quite a few, or as in like they're interchangeable. I feel like I've been giving the impression there's like one specific one. You can have multiple and everybody can in some way learn through each of those things. There was a recent University of Michigan article that called into question
而且对你来说不只有一种，就像通常有很多种，或者换句话说它们是可以互换的。我觉得我一直在给人一种印象，好像只有一种特定的。你可以有多种，每个人都可以在某种程度上通过其中的每一件事来学习。密歇根大学最近有一篇文章质疑了
the legitimacy of learning styles altogether because the idea that we can only learn in one way is kind of preposterous but the psychology does provide heaps of evidence for this fact. When you enjoy the methods you are using to learn, learn, you engage more, you absorb more, therefore you develop an enjoyable method for studying and enjoy the studying in itself. Even if it looks weird, even if you feel like nobody understands
学习风格的合法性，因为我们只能以一种方式学习的想法有点荒谬，但心理学确实为这一事实提供了大量证据。当你喜欢你用来学习的方法时，学习，你会更多地参与，吸收更多，因此你为自己开发了一种令人愉快的学习方法，并且乐在其中。即使它看起来很奇怪，即使你觉得没有人理解
it, having a method that relates to you personally and that you enjoy is always going to be more effective than a traditional method that bores you or doesn't interest you. This kind of brings me to My next tip, which is use unconventional ways of learning because I guess the more novel, the more memorable. And the more likely you are to integrate the information. The one I loved the most, which I'm now thinking about and I'm realizing this has a lot to say about me, but I used to record my notes as a voice note on my laptop. and I would convert it into an MP3 file for my phone so I could listen to the concepts as a podcast.
它，拥有一个与你个人相关且你喜欢的方法总是比一个让你感到无聊或不感兴趣的传统方法更有效。这让我想到我的下一个提示，那就是使用非常规的学习方式，因为我想越是新颖，就越令人难忘。而且你更有可能整合信息。我最喜欢的那一个，我现在回想起来，我意识到这对我有很多说明，但我过去常常把我的笔记作为语音便签录在我的笔记本电脑上。
How I did not realize this was going to be my career, I do not know. I cannot tell you. That was obviously a sign. But that was really effective for me. I'd also put classical music behind it sometimes. I used to play it to fall asleep because, and this has no evidence for it. Let me just say there's no evidence for this. but I used to be like, oh yeah, if I listen to it while I'm sleeping,
我会把它转换成手机的MP3文件，这样我就可以像听播客一样听这些概念。
that's more time for it to be absorbed into my memory. Like overnight, it's going to like infuse into my mind. That didn't work. I can tell you that now. But novelty of any kind, any method, primes your brain to learn. There's evidence for this. There was a 2020 study done with a bunch of high school students in Argentina
我当时怎么没意识到这会成为我的职业，我不知道。我无法告诉你。这显然是一个征兆。但这对真的很有效。我有时也会在它后面放古典音乐。我以前在睡觉时播放它，因为，而且这没有证据。让我直说吧，这没有证据，但我曾经想，哦，是的，如果我在睡觉时听它，
that puts students either in a novel environment or their school environment and showed them a geometrical shape, a geometrical object, a really random object. And it asked them to memorize, well, the researchers asked them to memorize it. And then they asked them 45 days later, if they remembered it, they asked them to draw the shape. And those in the novel situations had much better recall. Study in new locations. Use different colored pens.
那是让它被吸收进我的记忆的更多时间。就像一夜之间，它会融入我的脑海。那不管用。我现在可以告诉你了。但任何形式的新颖性、任何方法，都会促使你的大脑学习。这有证据。阿根廷的一群高中生在2020年做了一项研究
have a unique playlist for each subject, tie new concepts to a new flavor of gum. Anything that's, again, going to give a concept another dimension means it's going to be integrated differently and better, I guess. Okay, we are going to take a short break here before getting into my four final tips for studying effectively. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
把学生置于新颖的环境中或他们的学校环境中，向他们展示一个几何形状、一个几何物体、一个非常随机的物体。并要求他们记住，嗯，研究人员要求他们记住它。然后他们在45天后问他们，是否还记得，他们要求画出这个形状。处在陌生环境中的人记忆力要好得多。在新的地点学习。使用不同颜色的笔。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
为每个学科准备一个独特的播放列表，将新概念与新口味的口香糖联系起来。任何事情，再次强调，将为概念赋予另一个维度，这意味着它将以不同且更好的方式被整合，我想是的。好的，在我们进入关于有效学习的最后四个技巧之前，我们在这里做一个简短的休息。请继续收听。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的方法。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等对话，抛弃主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力造成的。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在I-Hart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金的胸部吗？
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of course. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
或者当坎耶说乔治·W·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·W·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
需要明确的是，1984年对我很重要，不仅因为当然。快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up
你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验
in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道我们什么时候做得够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
生活变成了输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯蒂·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你真正地做一个好人。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你的免费i-heart radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of...
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
在亚利桑那州服刑。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So this is a tip I wish, I wish I learned so not, but only kind of grasped. I would say in like my last two years of university, not all times are good times for studying. Your peak productivity hours may not be the same as others or the same as the, even the typical workday, which is based around what we are like a human circadian rhythm. Yes, we might all have the same circadian structure. but your peak productivity depends on your individual biology and it depends on your individual
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了。
rhythm. When I was in like the early days of university, I remember going to this, I don't know what it was, like a module or like a lecture. It was like on studying effectively. And in it the lecture or like the person leading it was like, your best study time is 9 a.m. to 12 p.m. and 3 p.m. to 7 p.m. I don't know where she got that from and I tried to stick with that for ages. I'd be like, no, I need to study 9 a.m. I got to be at the library until I realized like I was not getting a single thing done during that whole time. Like I'm a night out. I like working. I like studying. I like writing, creating after 7 p.m. I can focus for hours. I know my mom is the same. And we were actually having this conversation recently where I was like, how did you get so much work done when we
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，不。我发誓。我要做他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends》。
were kids, like she had three kids, and she was working like multiple jobs. And she was telling me how her peak performance hours were always for her like 10 p.m. to 2 a.m. So she would be working when we were asleep. And I was like, huh, that's where I get it. But there's another name for a person like this, obviously a night owl in comparison to those like 5 a.m. club early birds. And I just feel like if I tried to do those 5 a.m. wake-ups, I could never. never get anything done. That's not how I am programmed. You have to figure out how you are programmed. Researchers in 2021 tested participants on this with a series of cognitive tasks and they found that learning, memory, attention, they were all significantly better when people worked during their
相信我，宝贝。在iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。所以这是我希望，我希望我能学会而不是，但只是有点领悟的技巧。我想说在我大学的最后两年里，并非所有时间都是学习的好时机。你最高效的工作时间可能与其他人不同，甚至与典型的工作日也不同，典型工作日是围绕人类昼夜节律建立的。是的，我们可能都有相同的昼夜节律结构，但你的最高生产力取决于你的个人生物学，取决于你的个人
preferred time of day. A separate meta-analysis looked at over 7,000 evening people and morning people and they also looked at what they called their diurnal preferences. And a diurnal preference is basically when you prefer to be awake versus asleep. And what they found was that when they let people naturally work during their preferred time, their cognitive ability, their academic achievement, their memory, their problem solving, all improved. Even in school children, even in little tiny school children. This study even actually, it has a self-report questionnaire. you can take, what is the study called?
节奏。当我在大学早期的时候，我记得我去过这个，我不知道那是什么，像一个模块或一个讲座。是关于有效学习的。在讲座中，演讲者或主持的人说，你最佳的学习时间是上午9点到中午12点，以及下午3点到晚上7点。我不知道她是从哪里弄来这个的，我试着坚持了很久。我会想，不，我需要学习9点。我得在图书馆里，直到我意识到我在这整个时间内连一件事都没干完。就像我是个夜猫子。我喜欢工作。我喜欢学习。我喜欢在晚上7点之后写作、创作。我可以专注几个小时。我知道我妈妈也是这样。我们最近实际上在进行这种对话，当时我就像，当我们还是孩子时，你怎么能完成那么多工作，比如她有三个孩子，她同时做多份工作。她告诉我，对她来说，她的巅峰表现时间总是晚上10点到凌晨2点。所以当我们在睡觉时，她就会工作。我就想，哈，这就是我遗传自她的地方。但对于这样的人还有另一个称呼，与那些凌晨5点起床的早起鸟相比，显然是夜猫子。我只是觉得如果我试着在凌晨5点起床，我永远也无法完成任何事情。这不是我的编程方式。你必须弄清楚你是如何被编程的。2021年的研究人员用一系列认知任务对参与者进行了测试，他们发现当人们在他们的
I think it's called chronotype cognitive abilities and academic achievement from 2011, if you want to look it up. And in like the appendix, they'll have this. So you can figure out what your diurnal preference is, when the best time a day is for you. I think you probably already know. I think it's the time when you feel least tired doing work, whether that is 1 a.m. or 1 p.m. I think a crucial step to this is also being okay with not being
偏好时间工作时，学习、记忆、注意力都明显更好。另一项元分析研究了7000多名夜猫子和早起鸟，他们还研究了所谓的昼夜偏好。昼夜偏好基本上是你喜欢清醒还是睡觉的时间。他们发现的是，当他们让人们自然地在他们偏好的时间工作时，他们的认知能力、学业成就、记忆力、问题解决能力都有所提高。即使在学龄儿童中，甚至是小不点学龄儿童中。这项研究实际上，它有一份自我报告问卷。你可以做，这个研究叫什么？
productive when everyone else is being. A lot of studying, at least I found, was sometimes like appearance base, especially when you're like in a big college or in a big high school or in a big uni. And so sometimes like that there was pressure to sort of appear like you were busy even if you weren't getting anything done. So again, with this like body clock method, if you know you can get seven hours of work done in four hours if you start at 1 a.m. You don't need to be starting at 9 a.m. Take the morning off. Remember, efficiency is personal. It's not externally dictated. It's incredibly individualized. And if your goal is to get great grades, do it when it suits you best. Here's another reason why I loved working and I love studying late. And I guess it kind of makes up
我想它被称为2011年的 chronotype 认知能力和学业成就，如果你想查一下的话。在附录里，会有这个。所以你可以弄清楚你的昼夜偏好是什么，一天中什么时候对你来说是最好的时间。我想你可能已经知道了。我认为这是你做工作时感觉最不累的时间，无论是凌晨1点还是下午1点。我认为这其中的关键一步也是接受当别人都有生产力时自己没有生产力。很多学习，至少我发现，有时像是基于外表的，特别是当你在一所大学或一所大高中或一所大大学里时。所以有时会有压力，即使你没有完成任何事情，也要表现得好像你很忙。所以，再次强调，通过这种生物钟方法，如果你知道如果你从凌晨1点开始，你可以在四个小时内完成七个小时的工作。你不需要从上午9点开始。放个早晨假。记住，效率是个人的。它不是由外部决定的。它是极其个别化的。如果你的目标是取得好成绩，就在最适合你的时候去做。这就是为什么我喜欢工作和深夜学习的另一个原因。我想这有点弥补了
Tim number five. It's because it was romantic. And I believe, like the more romantic or sentimental you make studying, the better you are at it. You have to romanticise study. You have to make it glamorous. You have to make it charming. I don't know what other episode I spoke about this and I'm pretty sure I did, but I loved working late and I loved thinking about like all the other great, all the other. I just like thinking about like the great thinkers and writers who I admired who'd be like up by the candlelight who'd be like diligently working back in the day and like that was so I don't know I love the intimacy of it and how dedicated it felt and I think it's important to find an image a mental image of studying that is
第5点。因为这很浪漫。而且我相信，你把学习弄得越浪漫或越有感伤，你就会学得越好。你必须将学习浪漫化。你必须让它充满魅力。我不知道我在哪一集里说过这个，我很确信我说过，但我喜欢深夜工作，我喜欢想象所有那些伟大的人，所有其他伟大的。我只是喜欢想象那些我钦佩的伟大思想家和作家，他们会在烛光下起床，在过去的日子里努力工作，这真是，我不知道，我喜欢那种亲密感以及它感觉到的奉献精神，我认为找到一个对你很有吸引力的学习心理形象并在你学习时体现它是很重要的。一些其他的例子，比如我知道有人喜欢把自己想象成学者、知识分子、创始人，他们像，正在工作，是的，这是一个常见的例子，当他们清晨起床时，他们喜欢把自己想象成艺术家。无论需要什么来让你爱上学习的过程，而不仅仅是结果，你都必须去做。这是给你的另一个心理学秘诀。它实际上被称为努力悖论。爱上努力工作。很多心理学会说我们逃避努力是因为它成本高昂。我们想要选择阻力最小的路线。但你越是追求努力，它就越让人觉得具有内在价值。
attractive to you and embody it when you are studying some other examples like I know people who like to imagine themselves as scholars, intellectuals, founders who are like working, like, that's a common one, who like to imagine themselves as an artist when they're up early in the morning. Whatever it takes to make you fall in love with the process of studying, not just the outcome, you've got to do it. And that's another psychology hack for you. It's actually called the effort paradox. Fall in love with working hard. A lot of psychology will say we avoid effort because it's costly. and we want to choose the path of least resistance. But the more you pursue effort, the more it feels innately valuable.
而且它实际上增加了你正在努力的事情的价值。人们为了一个目标付出巨大努力时，可能会更重视它。这就是为什么我们喜欢宜家家具。这就是为什么我们，因为我们必须为它努力工作。因为有个人投资。我们付出努力的事情，是的，比如家具。我们组装的，或者像我们自己做的蛋糕，你知道，比起不需要付出努力的完全相同的东西，它感觉更有意义和更有价值。努力创造意义，这更有力量
And the more it actually increases the value of the thing that you are working towards. People may value a goal more when they work really hard for it. That's why we like IKEA furniture. It's why we, because we have to work hard for it. Because there's a personal investment. The things we put effort into, yeah, like furniture. we assemble, or like a cake we make ourselves, you know, it feels more meaningful and valuable than an identical thing that requires no effort. Effort creates meaning, which is more powerful
而且它实际上会增加你正在努力的事情的价值。人们为一个目标付出巨大努力时，可能会更珍视它。这就是为什么我们喜欢宜家家具。这就是为什么我们……因为我们必须为之付出努力。因为这里有个人的投入。我们付出了心血的东西，是的，比如我们组装的家具，或者我们自己做的蛋糕，你知道，它比不需要付出努力的同类东西感觉更有意义、更有价值。努力创造意义，这更有力量。
than motivation. You don't start studying because you love it. You start studying because you're, because you've invested effort and because that feels important. And so then the meaning follows. The meaning and the motivation follows effort, not the other way around. Does that make sense? you can read the paper I think it's a just called the effort paradox from 2018 if you want to understand this better but effort creates
比起动力，你不是因为热爱才开始学习的。你开始学习是因为你投入了精力，因为这感觉很重要。然后意义才会随之而来。意义和动力来源于付出，而不是相反。这说得通吗？如果你想更好地理解这一点，你可以去读读那篇论文，我想它就叫《努力的悖论》（2018年），但努力会创造出
meaning not motivation it's one of the best things I read when I was studying when I was at university it's basically another way of saying again like fall in love with hard work and pursue consistency basically it's another way
意义，而不是动力。这是我在大学读书时读过的最好的文章之一。这其实是另一种说法，就像“爱上努力工作，追求持之以恒”一样。这基本上是另一种
of saying consistency matters and consistency works, but it's just saying that in a different way, I guess. Let me move on to tip number seven. I think this was my most unhinged study tip. I used to pay myself to study. I'm going to explain this, but I knew from high school psychology that our brains respond to reward and regular positive enforcement. So when I would get paid or specifically when I would get tips when I was working at the Hawaiian bar or when I was working at the steak restaurant, I would have these envelopes in my drawer, like in my university death's drawer, and I would put like $20 bills, $5 bills, $10 bills in these envelopes, and I wouldn't label them.
表达方式，说的是坚持很重要，坚持会有用，但我想它只是换了一种说法。让我进入第七个建议。我想这是我最疯狂的学习技巧。我以前花钱让自己学习。我来解释一下，但我从高中心理学中了解到，我们的大脑会对奖励和定期的积极强化做出反应。所以当我拿到薪水时，或者具体来说，当我在夏威夷酒吧工作或者在牛排餐厅工作拿到小费时，我的抽屉里会有这些信封，比如我大学书桌抽屉里的信封，我会把20美元、5美元、10美元的钞票放进这些信封里，而且我不会在上面做标记。
I wouldn't know which had which. And every time I went to study, I would bring a single envelope with me. And only when I'd done a certain number of hours would I be allowed to open it. And I would be allowed to spend whatever money was in there or like add it to my wallet. because I didn't know how much money was in there, it kind of also tapped into principles of intermittent reinforcement or random reinforcement as well. And let me just say, like, it worked. It truly, truly worked so, so well. Like, I was basically bribing myself. Normally by like the time I think I'd done, I think I would give it to me myself like after three hours. Normally after,
我不知道哪个里面装的是多少钱。每次我去学习时，我都会随身带一个信封。只有当我学习了规定的时间后，我才被允许打开它。我可以用里面的钱或者把它放进钱包里。因为我不知道里面有多少钱，这在某种程度上也利用了间歇性强化或随机强化的原则。我直说了吧，这很管用。真的、真的管用，效果太棒了。这就像我在贿赂自己一样。通常到我觉得我已经学了的时候，我想我会给自己这个奖励，大概是在三个小时后。通常在，
like, I would have done two hours and I'd be really hungry or really bored and I'd want a snack and my university had this like little basic grocery store. And at two hours, I'd be like, I'm ready, but I would force myself to do that other hour because then I would get the reward. And obviously it was my money. Like I could open it at any time, but it would like really motivate me to just like push to that third hour. And I would obviously have breaks in between, like I'd go to the bathroom. I wasn't like sitting there with like those metal prongs, like opening my eyes. Like I would let myself get up and go around, but I wasn't allowed to leave the library or I wasn't allowed to go back to my dorm before those three hours were done or the next
比如，我学了两个小时，我会觉得很饿或很无聊，我想吃点零食，而我的大学里有这样一个像基础便利店一样的小店。到了两个小时的时候，我会想，我准备好了，但我会强迫自己再学一个小时，因为这样我才能得到奖励。显然这是我自己的钱。我随时可以打开它，但这真的能激励我坚持到第三个小时。当然，中间我也会休息，比如去上厕所。我不是那种坐在那里用金属夹子撑开眼睛学习的人。我会让自己站起来走动一下，但在那三个小时结束之前，我不被允许离开图书馆，也不被允许回到宿舍，或者接下来的
three hours after that because I couldn't open the envelope, which again, super strange. Tell me if you do this. I don't know anybody else who does this, but it worked. Okay, I don't know what tip we are up to here. But next, another big psychology hack that's very simple but very necessary is a limit. all distractions. Do not believe that you can study if your phone is right next to you. I used to use this self-control website blocker. I think I literally still have it on my computer. I would also give my, me and my friends were like we would give each other our phones and like
接下来的三个小时也是如此，因为我不能打开信封。再次强调，这超级奇怪。告诉我你会不会这样做。我不知道还有谁会这样做，但它确实管用。好了，我不知道我们讲到第几个技巧了。但接下来，另一个非常简单但又非常必要的重大心理学秘诀是：限制所有干扰。不要相信如果你的手机就在你旁边你还能学习。我以前用过一个自我控制的网站拦截器。我想我的电脑里现在还留着它。我还会把手机交出来，我和朋友们会把手机互相交给对方，比如
put them in our bags so they couldn't access them and like give them back when we were kind of ready to go. Anything to keep a distraction away from your desk or away from your study space is crucial. I cannot stress enough how much you need to be doing this, no matter how good you think your discipline is. We really do like to believe that discipline is like a personality trait, that some people are just more motivated or motivated enough to be able to sit there with their phone face down and not touch it and just simply not do anything with it. But psychology says, that's not true. Your brain is not designed to coexist peaceful. with distraction. Every notification, every open tab, every buzzing phone noise triggers what is called
把它们放进包里，这样我们就拿不到了，等我们准备走了再还给我们。任何能把干扰远离你的书桌或学习空间的东西都至关重要。我怎么强调都不为过，你有多需要这样做，不管你认为你的自律有多好。我们真的很想相信自律就像是一种性格特质，有些人就是更有动力，或者动力十足，能够把手机屏幕朝下放在那里，不碰它，就单纯地什么都不做。但心理学表明，事实并非如此。你的大脑生来就不是为了与干扰和平共处的。每一个通知、每一个打开的标签页、每一个嗡嗡作响的手机噪音都会引发所谓的
attention or capture. Even if you don't consciously check it, a part of you is still, oh, aware that something's going on. Just knowing your phone is nearby is actually enough to reduce your working memory and cognitive capacity. There is literal research showing that performance improves simply by putting your phone in another room. Simply by giving it to to somebody else, not putting it on silent, not putting it face down, gone, putting it away. This is why externalizing self-control works so well. Website blockers, app limits, a friend. That's not a sign that you have weak discipline, like they're signs of psychological intelligence. You are removing the need for constant decision-making and constantly needing to stop your brain
注意力捕获。即使你没有刻意去查看它，你的一部分仍然会意识到有什么事情正在发生。仅仅知道你的手机就在附近，实际上就足以降低你的工作记忆和认知能力。确实有研究表明，只需把手机放在另一个房间，表现就会有所提升。只需把它交给我人，不要调成静音，不要把屏幕朝下扣着，而是拿开，把它收起来。这就是为什么外化自律效果如此之好。网站拦截器、应用限制、一个朋友。这并不标志着你自律能力薄弱，相反，它们是心理聪明的表现。你消除了不断做决定的需求，不再需要不断地阻止你的大脑
from doing what it wants to most, which is to take the quick dopamine, which is, to take the destruction. Finally, and I should have said this one earlier when I was talking about my money envelope reward scheme, but study with other people as a reward. Now, I wouldn't do this all the time, only when I was really serious in like a real crunch period. But I knew that as much as money was a fantastic treat as an extrovert, as a social butterfly, especially at university. Being around other people and having a little chit-chat, that was a much greater reward for me. So I manipulated that. I manipulated that desire to force myself to work harder. There is a powerful doponogenic reward loop at play.
去做它最想做的事——也就是获取快速的多巴胺，也就是分心。最后，我应该在我讲钱信封奖励机制时更早地说这一点，那就是把和别人一起学习作为一种奖励。现在，我不会一直这样做，只有在我处于真正的冲刺阶段、非常认真的时候才会这样。但我知道，正如金钱是一个极好的奖励一样，作为一个外向的人、一个社交达人，特别是在大学里。和别人在一起，聊聊天，对我和说是一个更大的奖励。所以我操纵了这一点。我利用了这种渴望来强迫自己更努力地工作。这其中发挥着强大的多巴胺能奖励循环作用。
when you're studying alone, followed by letting yourself study with other people as a treat, your brain begins to associate effort with anticipated connection, making the initial work feel more tolerable, maybe even motivating. If I knew I'd get to go sit with my friends at the end or like go and annoy them or hang out with them, it just made me want to work harder to get through the, the time. That's the whole point of having, of having that reward. So those are my tips. Those are my study tips that I swore by. I'm going to quickly summarize them for you now. Firstly, the biggest thing you should be doing, if you're not doing anything else on this list,
当你独自学习时，接着把自己当作奖励去和别人一起学习，你的大脑开始将努力与预期的社交联系联系起来，这使得最初的工作感觉更能忍受，甚至可能更有动力。如果我知道结束后能和朋友们坐在一起，或者去烦他们、和他们一起闲逛，这就会让我想要更努力地工作，好熬过这段时间。这就是设置这个奖励的全部意义所在。所以这些就是我的建议。这些是我坚信不移的学习技巧。我现在为你们快速总结一下。首先，你应该做的最重要的事情，如果你在这个清单上什么都没做的话，那就是
encode information with personal significance. Use my note-taking manuscript method. Figure out your preferred learning style. Not your exact learning style. We know there's not a single one, but your preferred. Utilize novelty in whatever form. Study during your most productive hours, not, even if they're not necessarily the socially applauded hours. Romanticized studying, romanticized studying to activate that effort paradox that we were talking about. Pay yourself to study. Eliminate distractions. Use social study as a reward. And one final, one final one final one. as much as you can, integrate the information into your conversations. Teach other people, teach your parents, slip it into like calls with clients or like when you're
将信息与个人意义进行编码。使用我的笔记手稿方法。找出你偏好的学习风格。不是指确切的某种学习风格。我们知道并没有单一的风格，而是你偏好的那种。以任何形式利用新奇事物。在你最高效的时间段学习，而不是，即使它们不一定是社会上赞许的时间段。将学习浪漫化，将学习浪漫化，以激活我们刚才讨论过的努力悖论。花钱让自己学习。消除干扰。把社交学习作为一种奖励。还有一个最后的、最终的、终极的建议。尽可能地将这些信息融入到你的日常对话中。教给其他人，教给你的父母，在与客户的通话中顺便提一下，或者在你为别人端咖啡时提一下。任何人，任何事，任何愿意听的人，让他们参与到你的学习中来。这简直就是这个播客最初小规模起步的方式。我想更多地谈论心理学来巩固我的理解。我想结合我的朋友们的生活和我的家人的生活来谈论它。然后，我们就走到了这里。看，结果就是这样。非常感谢大家的收听。希望这些小贴士对你们有所帮助。如果你使用了其中的任何一个并且觉得有用，请告诉我。如果你能听到这里，说明你的注意力真的很强。谢谢。在下方留言吧。你最疯狂、最古怪的学习秘诀是什么？我想要那些奇奇怪怪的。如果你像我一样花钱让自己学习，我想知道，因为我觉得我只有，
serving somebody coffee. Anyone, anything, anyone who wants to listen, get them involved in your learning. This is literally in a small way how this podcast started. I wanted to talk more about psychology to integrate my understanding. And I wanted to talk about it in reference to my friends' lives and my family's lives. And that's, this is how we're here. Look how that turned out. So thank you so much for listening. I hope these tips are helpful. Let me know if you use any of them and if they are useful. If you have made it this far, great attentional skills. Thank you. Leave a comment down below. What is your most unhinged weird study hack? I want the weird ones. and if you pay yourself to study like I did, I want to know it because I think I've only,
我觉得我只认识另外一个这样做的人，而且我很确定当她说她在花钱时，那是她父母的钱。所以我想知道你是否也这样做，以及它对你是否有用。我想现在人们不怎么用现金了。不过，是的，那些都是美好的时光。我很怀念它。我真的很怀念学习的时光，伙计们。如果你现在也还在学习，别把它当作理所当然。晚上的唯一工作就是和朋友们坐在一起，或者只是坐下来学习，这种感觉真的太有趣了——这绝对是梦想中的工作，梦想中的工作。再次感谢大家的收听，希望你们喜欢这期节目。确保你在现在收听的任何地方关注我们，订阅我们，或者开启通知，这样你就会知道当
I think I know like one other person who did that and I'm pretty sure when she said she was paying herself. It was her parents. So I want to know if you do that and if it works for you. I guess people don't really use cash anymore. But yeah, those are the good times. I miss it. I really miss studying you guys. Like if you're still studying at the moment as well, like don't take it for granted. There was something so fun about like your only job for the evening being just like, to sit with your friends or just to like sit and learn like genuinely dream job dream job so thank you again for listening i hope you enjoyed the episode make sure that you are following us wherever you are listening right now that you are subscribed or that you have notifications turned on so you know when
新节目发布时能第一时间听到。如果你想了解幕后花絮、获取节目摘要、知道新节目何时发布以及我们何时需要听众投稿，你也可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是@thatpsychology podcast。这是参与进来的好方法。如果你正在寻找完整的节目文字稿，你也可以在Substack上关注我们。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧精神、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
new episodes come out you can also follow us on instagram at that psychology podcast if you want to see behind the scenes you want episode summaries you want to know when new episodes are coming out and uh when we want people's listener contributions. That's a great way to get involved there. You can also follow us on Substack for full episode transcripts if you are looking for those. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。在它成为疯狂的一年之前。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
欢迎收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。桑德兰女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sondland's, correct?
我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是被爱所困。
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被爱所困》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝，在Iheart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说要相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。